[Music]
very soon in the UK we'll have something
known as machs and carers law named
after a little boy who received a heart
transplant and the little girl who
donated it
this new law means that we will all be
presumed organ donors unless we decide
to opt outs over in the States however
where donation is based on an opt-in
model they are thinking creatively about
how to plug their organ donation
shortfall paying special attention to
living donors debate has broken out
about whether financial incentives
should be offered in return for organs
as they can be for example in Iran the
alarm bells ring loud to me on this one
because paying people for body parts
should surely be avoided at all costs
it's a tricky one I think you're right
to raise it I don't think I agree with
you though I mean I think we can all
agree that the opt the opt-in model is
probably a good thing but where it's
been tried and wails and so on so far
the results show it doesn't make it
where it's been tried essentially that
you're presumed that you will that you
will donate unless you say you won't it
doesn't seem to have made that much
difference what has made a difference in
Iran for example is where people are
paid for organ donation the Americans
have really bothered about this because
it's it's a big deal it's particularly a
big deal for by the way amongst African
Americans three times as likely as
average to suffer from or to need a
kidney transplant I understand the ick
factor here I really get that but the
question is do we want to save lives and
to be honest I think we've already sold
the past on this issue of as it were
sharing organs I mean frankly we pay
we've paid for ages for sperm donors and
now we pay for surrogacy the average
cost the average amount we pay
7,000 to 15,000 now we say that for
expenses but in reality the truth is the
money is changing hands and I think I
get your I get your feeling about it but
the question is do we want to save
people's lives or not and if this is a
way to do it then we should do it but
for me the question of course you should
want to save people's lives but offering
people like if you look a place like
around it's often life-changing amounts
of money to you know cut open it's not
the same as spare you know it's the
cutting open your body just sell a body
part and when you're looking around
there's like on lamppost and store you
got like picture like pictures and and
things you know kidney and this my blood
type and force it and then you've got a
black market that pops up where you can
get more money and the private well it's
not private but under the black market I
just think there's something where do
you draw the line if we incentivize you
to cut open your body I just think it's
a bit but you're the one who is usually
at this table saying we should trust
ordinary people's instinct on moral
questions and not tell them what to do
what you want to do well you're what
you're saying is let's protect the
potential donor from their worst
instincts surely we need to trust people
to deal with that it's a moral choice I
agree but let's make let people other
people who make their own moral choices
rob moral choices from a position of
death financial desperation and that no
I just wanted to bring in the National
Kidney Foundation and what they have to
say about this issue profiteering as a
result of organ donation means that
people could be coerced or forced into
donation exploitation of donors
worldwide is a serious issue that takes
advantage of those who are most
underprivileged and vulnerable it has
been demonstrated that selling kidneys
has little long-term impact on the
sellers financial security and may
actually end up worse financially
medically and psychologically shall be
opting out and the reason is and this
isn't because yeah I don't want my
organs harvested and the reason for that
is that I had a brother who at the age
17 and I might have told the story
before so apologies if you have but it
is very pertinent aney through the age
of seventeen was catapulted out of the
backseat of a car headfirst into a
lamppost in Camberwell southeast London
he was then taken to the brilliant
King's College Hospital in 1968 I
remember to this day it was May the 11th
1968 where my parents were informed that
he was dead and they wanted to harvest
his organs and my parents and they said
and pardon the language but it was of
the time he will remain a [ __ ] he
will have that was the language of the
time in 1968 and he will have no quality
of life my parents balked at that and a
brilliant surgeon saved my brother's
life he was unconscious from May the
11th 1968 to August the 31st 97 on
conscious I remember it every bout and
he went on to have 34 years of life as a
reporter on the Daily Mirror 30 40 he
died 19 years ago last week he had lost
the sight of an eye his left arm was
slightly spasticated he spoke as if he'd
had a minor stroke
he was an absolute tower in my life and
in my children's life massive massive
figure in my children's life that's why
I will not and I believe body belongs to
me not the state you know that is a very
terrible it sounds like a medical
mistake this person you know wasn't in
that situation they shouldn't be
harvesting organs but if you'd died and
you'd actually died wouldn't you want
you know I'm not talking about anomalies
if I wanted a kidney I'd probably have a
different view but I'm so informed as a
young man by growing up by that
experience a very difficult thing for me
to move on from I'm sure you can
appreciate we should give people the
right to make that kind of moral choice
and to be honest I had not heard that
before and I I can see why you take the
view you take may I ask you a question
if the person who needed the organ was
your son or your daughter yep would you
go no I get absolute I'm arguing against
myself Trevor you're absolutely right
and
it was me you're absolutely right well
in 2002 my husband was on the organ
donor list for a life-saving liver
transplant and there were no organs
available and he was on he we had very
small children then and we waited and
waited and we would ring Addenbrooke's
where he was on the transplant register
and we'd say any and they'd say no then
they'd say pray for a cold winter
because you know your only hope is a
road traffic accidents that were they
call RTA's and it wasn't a very cold
winter but in February suddenly we got
the call that there was after four
months and he was about to be struck off
the register because protocols mean if
you are not going to benefit from a
donor organ then their donor organ has
to go to a more suitable candidate so we
were very lucky and the system of
presumed consent wasn't operational it
was an opt-in system not an opt-out
system and I would see and very grateful
that he there was a family agreed on a
deathbed to have their son's organs used
one of which the liver which beneficial
my husband has saved his life gave the
children their father back so to me this
is a really emotional subject and I am
very much in favor of the option Kiera's
law and we're going to hear from the
government minister in a minute but I
have to say that my husband agrees with
Nick really thinks despite having
benefited from a donor organ the the
state should not be involved in the
capture and retrieval of organs can we
just hear from the minister on Cara's
Law Max and Cara's donor the incredible
gift of organ donation means that one
family's tragedy can bring new hope for
another at the moment the chances of
this lower because of the shortage of
available organs and tissues Max and
Cara's law can help change that saving
many more lives every year I encourage
everyone to take this opportunity to
have a conversation with their families
and friends about their organ donation
wishes and register a decision that was
Minister for care Helen Whaley can I ask
a devil's advocate question yes so it's
not about the Finance
since what other people what are you
guys thoughts if you opt out so you said
I don't want to be a donor and you've
opted out so you're on the register is
saying opt out leave me alone if you
then find yourself in a health situation
where you need a donor to save your life
if you've opted out what do you think
that that should affect your ability to
receive I get your argument that I'm
gonna say I get your it's a real moral
dilemma isn't it I would say